three and a half years ago amid
persistent opposition protests
venezuela's embattled president nicolas
maduro
announced he was unilaterally calling
for a constituent assembly
to rewrite the constitution written by
his predecessor
deceased president hugo chavez
i summon the native constituent power to
achieve the peace
that the republic needs to overthrow the
fascist coup and so that the people with
their sovereignty
will be able to impose peace harmony and
a true
national dialogue
even appeals from the pope couldn't stop
him from forming a 500 member body
with superpowers above all other
institutions
critics were quick to predict that its
real aim was to annihilate the
opposition-controlled parliament
and consolidate a dictatorship
indeed the assembly's most notable
achievement was to strip more than 30
opposition deputies of their
parliamentary immunity
so that they could be arrested and tried
for allegedly inciting violence or
treason
it's fairly brazen
it's clear now that uh
as it was indeed of course from the
beginning but it's even clearer now
that the intention was merely to provide
a kind of rubber stamp parliament
for the maduro government so that he
could pass
ostensibly at least past laws many of
which have
been extremely repressive do you know of
any other country in the world where
something like this has happened
certainly i would imagine it has to be
the only instance of a constitutional
a constitutional a constituent assembly
rather
that has not even debated a single
article
of a proposed new constitution now that
the ruling socialist party will take
total control of the legislature on
january 5th
after highly contested elections the
constituent assembly is being dissolved
just as quickly as it was created
we're handing over a country in peace in
peace in peace
with a newly elected legislature with
diverse representation that will assume
the challenge of maintaining
constitutionality
cabello says they've done their duty
without having changed
a comma of the original constitution
not say critics that that was ever the
point
lucia newman al jazeera